[Applaus]
2018 war ohne frage eine zäsur und der
anfang vom ende der ära merkel gibt ja
experten die behaupten die frau muss die
kanzlerschaft schon bald an ak abgeben
und was bleibt von angela merkel zehn
jahre aufschwung oder dass 20 prozent
der deutschen von diesem aufschwung
original nichts hatten naja sie ist ja
eine pragmatische uneitler person und
ich freue mich jetzt schon auf ihre
große emotionale abschiedsrede im
kanzleramt
so jetzt hoffe ich dass ich einigermaßen
alles gemacht habe ja danke
nicht mehr vor wird super
denn reich wird super und was kriegt
eine frau zum abschied die eigentlich
schon alles hat genau ein lied
seit 13 jahren
[Musik]
warst du immer da
was für unser land so viel
nicht getan die schulen sind
erst recht ruhig in deutschland doch
stehe ich habe selten 3g nach all den
jahren
[Musik]
wie sagst du [ __ ] euch geben
das gewissen wird dich die
auto-industrie
[Musik]
brüssel hast dich wie die pest
beim thema
gast ist juncker hat sich eingemischt
[Applaus]
[Musik]
das jetzt mal
zunächst war
dies führt dich doch komplett
oder auch com
für
da und die bahn
mit dem zug in die uckermark war
[Musik]
[Applaus]
der uni köln
was kann und jetzt tun
perfekte weiter
gross gesehen
ja
es werden bis dahin schon
[Applaus]
[Musik]